it's wonderful to see this room so
packed it really is so thank you
everybody for coming special thanks to a
laundry for bringing her class Katherine
I guess you've brought a class and I see
students from my own class here welcome
to everyone I'm Laura Chilcott Sookie
I'm associate director of the Center for
the critical analysis of social
difference I'd like to welcome you to
what is the second in our series of
keywords roundtable discussions doing my
closing that door that be late thank you
before I introduce our very
distinguished speakers I'd like to tell
you a little bit about the center and
then give you a kind of quick genealogy
of the keywords series a sense of what
we're trying to do here and also what we
imagine for the future so ccisd Center
for the critical analysis of social
difference ccas d is the product of an
ambitious and historic collaboration
among five different institutes and
centers at columbia the institute for
research in african american studies the
center for the study of ethnicity and
race the institute for comparative
literature and society the Barnard
Center for Research on women and the
Institute for Research on women and
gender at heart Cece ASD is an Advanced
Study Center that promotes innovative
interdisciplinary scholarship on the
role of gender sexuality ethnicity and
race in global dynamics of power and
inequality we are actively and
determinedly eking out a space here to
think differently across between against
the disciplines that are our other home
here at Columbia and beyond among the
key vocabularies of the center is of
course social difference and so this
vocabulary is actually a really good
segue to
our keyword for today intersectionality
so I want to say just a word about
social difference each of the Centers
for working projects and I want to
encourage you all to go to our website
social difference org to learn more
about the projects before working
projects that we have each of these
projects is invested in looking at
social differences in a wide range of
domains and from a wide range of
locations for example the production of
archives the lives of those at the
social margins in neoliberal locations
or across national borders the
organization of stigma injury or
violence these are just a few examples
and because we are seldom or more
precisely never looking at social
difference directly but rather always
through or in a way that's informed by
our unique disciplinary locations and
theoretical investments we can get a lot
out of mixing things up a little bit
throwing various modes of looking right
up against each other talking keywords
and exposing the different kinds of work
are critical languages do the various
ways they help us to ask good questions
but also the ways or critical languages
may limit our capacity to ask certain
other ones hence keywords that's what
this this series is really is really all
about as a series keywords is designed
to bring into conversation thinkers from
different disciplinary and theoretical
locations in order to explore the ways
that we think about and deploy and often
push back against fundamental critical
vocabularies it's an attempt to generate
out of the mashup of these modes of
looking some new vocabularies and new
methodologies for thinking about
inequality and social difference
intersection al
is one of several key terms that we are
always grappling with in our work at the
center necessarily perhaps given our
investment here in a self-consciously
interdisciplinary approach to social
difference intersectionality is also a
provocative keyword for us due in part
to the combination of the kinds of
questions that it raises about
difference questions about power and
also the analytical challenges or
limitations that it introduces today
Catherine Frankie Kendall Thomas and
Nefertiti ADR will address this keyword
now a little bit about our speakers
Catherine Frankie is professor of law at
Columbia Law School and director for the
center of gender and sexuality law she
rides on a range of topics including
same-sex marriage politics civil rights
law sex discrimination feminist legal
theory and sexual harassment her current
works in progress include of modena job
comes to columbia sexuality nationalism
and global governance and the law school
and the university rethinking the study
of law from within and without the law
school catherine is also a fabulous
writer and a spot on blogger and
Catherine I hope you don't mind if I
make a pitch for your blog with an amp
in part because I am a regular reader of
it I love it you can find Katherine's
blog at blogs law columbia.edu it's
great Kendall Thomas is the Nash
professor of law at Columbia Law School
and director of the Center for the Study
of law and culture he's co-editor of
critical race theory the key writings
that founded the movement and what's
left of theory his teaching and research
interests include us and comparative
constitutional law human rights legal
philosophy feminist legal theory
critical race theory and law and
sexualities he's a founding member of
the majority action caucus have act up
the aids coalition to unleash power and
the AIDS prevention action Lee
he currently serves as a member and vice
chair of the board of directors of the
gay men's health crisis nefertiti ADR is
chair of the Women's Studies program at
Barnard College and a former director of
CC ASD so it's so lovely to have
Nefertiti back she is most recently the
author of things fall away Philippine
literature's historical experience and
tangential makings of globality her
academic interest include transnational
and third world feminism's post-colonial
theory critical theories of race and
subjectivity literary and social theory
cultural studies of the asia-pacific
region and philippine studies she's
currently working on a book project
entitled discourse on empire living
under the rule of permanent war and
beginning a new research project
entitled schooling national subjects
experience and education in US colonial
Philippines welcome to you all we're
going to give each participant an
opportunity to speak up here at the
podium and then we will open it up for
discussion if everyone can turn off
their cellphones and also just to
remember to fill out the the release
form the four because we're videotaping
and then to hand it back up here thank
you
Thank You Laura welcome everybody I this
event is a little bit more intimate but
I think we even plan so I'm just so
thankful you came and it's since Laura
citizen email a little while ago several
months ago and said intersectionality
discuss and so that's what we're here to
do I think right that's our charge so
I'm just going to talk a little bit
about intersectionality and then Kendall
is going to talk a little bit more about
it and then deputy is going to tell us
how we got it all wrong or right or say
some more things about it so there are
three basic texts that I think launched
the idea of intersectionality
particularly in the legal literature
which is from where I hail but I think
it's also where the NP idea then moved
out of law into larger scholarship and
activism really the first is Kimberly
Crenshaw's dmart d marginalizing the
intersection of race and sex a black
feminist critique of anti-discrimination
doctrine feminist theory and anti-racist
practice kimberle Crenshaw is here with
us today so she will be an even better
representer of the ideas in those in
this paper then surely we will be the
second is Angela Harris's PS race and
essentialism in feminist legal theory
and these two papers came out basically
at the same time then the third I'm
going to talk a little bit about or at
least we should be aware of is a
follow-up article that Professor
Crenshaw wrote several years after the
first one mapping the margins
intersectionality identity politics and
violence against women of color in here
she elaborates further some of the ideas
she began in the first piece and I know
that some of you that Barnard students
who are here today in particular we're
reading this for today in interesting
ways i think the mapping the margins
piece has had a larger life or is been
serialized in readers almost more than
her initial conceptualization of the of
the the idea of intersectionality both
harris and crenshaw begin these first a
sort of conception
lotions of an idea of intersectionality
with a reference to literature which I
find interesting Harris has a epigram
from enta sake Sean Hayes for colored
girls which interestingly enough is also
coming out as a movie right now as you
know she begins Harris does being alive
and being a woman and being colored is a
metaphysical dilemma and in so many ways
that is what this concept is designed to
address Crenshaw begins her first piece
with Gloria ho the title of Gloria halls
book all the women are white all the
blacks are men but some of us are brave
and both of them in these pieces do at
various points Harris almost a little
bit more than friendship we literature
with law with life with politics in
interesting ways they are deeply
interdisciplinary forms of scholarship
both of them I think are building on an
idea that was in some ways first
articulated by Elizabeth Spellman in in
essential woman from 1988 and in some
ways we could say that the whole idea
has as its Genesis Dubois and his idea
of dual consciousness or multiple
consciousness much much earlier so let
me quote for a second from Crenshaw his
first piece that in a way frames the
question as she saw it it's a little
weird to talk about you in the third
person here but bear with me here so she
says I want to suggest that the single
access framework that of thinking race
or sex alone at a time erases black
women in the conceptualization
identification and remediation of race
and sex discrimination by limiting
inquiry to the expression of otherwise
privileged members of the group in other
words in race discrimination cases
discrimination tends to be viewed in
terms of sex or class privilege excuse
me in other words in race discrimination
cases discrimination tends to be viewed
in terms of set it of sex or class
privileged blacks and in sex
discrimination cases the focus is on
race and class privileged women so sex
is white and race is male as
she sets it up as the problem that needs
to be addressed and harris does as well
in many respects what I think Crenshaw
is doing in this first piece is
responding to a kind of formalization or
the formalization of sexual violence and
sex discrimination within the white
feminist community at the time and
particularly i would say that catherine
cannons work was a target specifically
of Harris's article and the way in which
Catherine MacKinnon understood sex
discrimination as a universalizing and
totalizing structure that all women
experience and in many ways in the same
ways and that women of color just have
that much more they have to deal with
but we have to start with sex
discrimination as something all women
share in the same ways and then women
who are have a different class different
sexuality different nationality
different race than that which is the
privileged one in a sense have a piling
on effect this is what Crenshaw and
harris i think wanted to address is that
we're not talking about layering we're
talking about and when we talk about the
experiences of women of color and the de
marginalization of women of color we
have to think differently so the
paradigm is one of proposing a different
approach to this Crenshaw offers in the
first piece an example from a law case
degraffenreid versus General Motors
which is from 1976 where there were
women of color african-american women
who claimed that they were being
discriminated against at General Motors
mom by virtue of their not being hired
or promoted in ways in keeping with both
their skills and other equally skilled
people in the in the workforce the court
was unwilling to see the discrimination
that these women suffered because they
said look General Motors has hired all
these women white women and General
Motors too tired all these black men so
it can't be discriminating against women
or acting in a sexually discriminatory
way because look here the women and it
can't be acting in a racially
discriminatory way because look we can
point to all of these black people that
work here black men and black women were
left out and it's a perfect case for
both framing the problem and then
offering a discussion of why
law does this easily and I do think
there's a way in which very much the
problem gets framed as one within law
and in a legally positivistic way of
thinking in axes single axis pren shaw
tells us harris focuses on rape and her
first piece and criticizes particularly
white feminist theorizing about sexual
violence as a form of sex discrimination
and it spends most of her time or good
chunk of her time in her piece on on
Catherine McKinnon's work in order to
point out how the history of rape for
african-american women and the reality
of rape today for african-american women
is very different than it is for white
women in so many important respects
going all the way back of course to
enslavement and the kind of sexual
violence that enslaved women experienced
whether it was as part of producing more
slaves or the kind of sexual violence
that happened in the domestic sphere
warehouse slaves female house slaves
were vulnerable all the time to sexual
violence from the men who owned them to
the idea that black women could not be
rape abul both during enslavement but
certainly after to the fact that they
could not testify in court police did
not pay attention to the to the violence
that that african-american women
suffered she cites the example of Joann
little as a more contemporary example
and the general unrest and
responsiveness of the police to the
claims of sexual violence by
african-american women but she also
found it extremely important to point
out that rape is a racially inflected
issue for way in ways in the
african-american community that it is
not in the white community insofar as
charges of rape have been used against
black men for so long and so don't so
damagingly and recounts that to so much
of the point that Harris wants to make
is that for african-american women race
frames and gives meaning to what sexual
violence means as much if not more so
than sex does and McKinnon's and the
traditional feminist account at the time
of sexual violence and of rape erases
all of that both material and
ideological
rape and her her job is to contribute
that story so what what Crenshaw is
doing and what what Harris are doing is
to move beyond this idea of compound
forms of discrimination and think of
discrimination for women of color in
particular as a synergistic an
intersectional experience that isn't
just adding race and mixing as someone
as often said often says about what
mckinnon doesn't her work so let me give
you a quote from again from from
Crenshaw in the first article on an
analogy she uses that sort of animates
and motivates the idea of intersection
so consider an analogy to traffic in an
intersection coming and going in all
four directions discrimination like
traffic through the intersection may
flow in one direction and it may flow in
and another if an accident happens in an
intersection it can be caused by cars
traveling from any number of directions
and sometimes from all of them similarly
if a black woman is harmed because she
is at the intersection her injury could
result from sex discrimination or race
discrimination hence the idea of the
intersection so both and race and sex
are going on and race and sex
discrimination are going on at the same
time as she describes it now I've always
found that intersectional metaphor a
little hard to get my mind around and
and of course these are just the
beginning the first iterations of these
ideas but let me offer some problems or
ideas to think about it in response to
this initial formulation of what
intersectional identity means the first
is is intersectionality a conception of
identity or conception of injury to some
in some respects what we what we imagine
with this intersectional idea is there's
this person standing there a subject in
the social who gets hit by or a slammed
in certain it really in the in the
description of it by race and sex or is
it racism and sexism
and in that sense I think in much of the
writing and not just I don't want to pin
this only on Harrison Crenshaw but in
much of the writing that is followed the
this is a confusion I think that works
through many much of this writing is
whether we're talking about a conception
of identity or conception of injury how
is one or how should one be disentangled
from the other or are they so
interrelated to one another that one
might want to understand identity as an
injury a question not asked or answered
in these early papers but one certainly
worth asking and thinking through second
is there lurking behind the idea of
intersectionality a notion of the sort
of a pre social human a kind of deep
liberal humanism that human arrives on
the scene and then these identity
categories happen to them or
discrimination on some level happens to
them again to go back to the idea of the
difference between identity and injury
there's almost a raw Xion sort of
feeling in the way that this is
conceptualized that there's the the
subject behind the veil or before the
veil who emerges into the social and
then it slammed in some way by sexism or
racism or we can enumerate or elaborate
other types of forms of identity next in
some ways I think what these early
formulations of intersectionality do is
not escape the essentialism in the
humanism which to which they are they
purport to be taking aim but in a sense
reiterate or essential eyes again just
with greater specificity come on in and
lay on the table
nobody called the fire department right
is what's going on here merely a kind of
enumeration with greater specificity if
you think of google or mapquest where
you push the + button and you get down
closer and closer in your mapping
project that you're able to see
individual streets and houses with
greater specificity is that what this is
doing is just essentialism and identity
politics at a greater or finer level or
granular level of enumeration Harris's
project I think shifts in a slightly
different direction in that at some
point I think it collapses into a kind
of standpoint epistemology of each
person knows their own experience can
and should narrate their own experience
and should not have others narrate speak
for them so the much of her pieces about
silencing effects and the erasure that
happens when white women speak for all
women or black men speak for all black
people and so she's interested in a kind
of standpoint epistemological project of
giving voice to those who don't fit in
either of those categories third third
fourth fifth i'm not sure where I am
because I know I have a minute left so
the last couple of things I want to just
put on the table here are is the idea of
intersectionality only one that has
purchase or use for marginalized groups
or do we want to say that everyone has a
intersectional identity minus white
woman lesbian you know I could keep
doing it but it's not intersectionality
isn't only something that's useful for
mapping the margins it may also be
important for matching everything
mapping everything and these two pieces
don't do that but we can't expect early
work to do everything right so that's
another question that's long front for
it next question is is there a way in
which these early conceptions over
determine the subjugation and the
minority identity of the subjects about
which they speak and that is to say can
we imagine situations where sex and sex
by that I mean
female or a woman is actually an
endowment not a disadvantage and here
I'm stepping a little bit on what I know
that Professor Thomas is going to want
to talk about which is that in some
respects and in some contexts
african-american women are less
marginalized or differently empowered
than our african-american men so is the
my twine or advising legacy a woman
working the same in each context when it
is intersectional II taken up with other
Michael minority Singh identities and I
think we have to say no but let's say a
lot more about that I think yep what the
last of it last things I'm sitting down
is of course we want to think more
richly about multiple other identity
sexuality class citizenship all sorts of
things which are referenced in the
footnotes but not necessarily taken up
in these initial pieces and that is
certainly important work for all of us
to do thanks
hello everyone it is a pleasure to be
here and to be participating in this
conversation at ear way and I thank you
for see a deer way under the auspices of
the program for the critical analysis of
social difference thank you very much
captain for correcting me and i have i
believe about 15 minutes right so i want
to talk about the question of
intersectionality primarily in the
context of the work of kimberle Crenshaw
because it is kimberle Crenshaw over the
course of a number of years in
conversations private and public who has
engaged my own thinking and challenged
being most deeply in thinking about the
utility of the concept of
intersectionality both as a framework
for understanding how racial power works
where Rachel color works and against
whom it works and for developing
positive programs of fighting the use of
racial power so let me say that most of
my comments are going to revolve around
an article which I suspect many of you
in the room have read for those of you
who haven't I recommend it to you highly
and that is the Stanford article mapping
the margins on intersectionality and
sexual violence because it seems to me
to lay out beautifully each of the
central claims of the theory of
intersectionality as articulated by
professor Crenshaw the theory makes
claims on at least four dimensions one
is the epistemic dimension which makes a
set of arguments about the categories
through which race is known or
recognized and argues that the category
of race as it has been used with in
african-american communities that is to
say with an intra community
conversations and then as a politics and
external politics has been formed by and
shaped in the image of black men the
second is an ontological claim which has
to do with the experiences through which
race is lived and the claim here is that
black anti-racist politics is
overwhelmingly proceeded through a
narrative that privileges the lived
experience of race among black men the
third is a normative claim and this is a
claim which has two elements one is a
claim about legal norms um what should
anti-discrimination law do and a second
related plain normative claim is about
political norms what should anti-racist
or anti-sexist politics do now I want to
focus on the following question in here
I'm quoting from the mapping the margins
article if history and context determine
the utility of identity politics how do
we understand identity politics today
now intersectionality was one answer to
that question and the answer it offered
was as follows starting from the major
premise that the first are most
effective most practical anti-racist
politics the the most effective politics
for dismantling if you will the racial
state is identity politics
intersectionality moves on to make an
argument from a minor premise that we
understand identity politics as a
coalition of politics that recognizes
and accommodates the multiple dimensions
of the identity that is being organized
around or around which the politics in
question is being is being organized now
the position as a political position was
a claim about racial pragmatism and to
see why this is so I think it's
important to understand attention within
critical race theory itself that can be
captured in terms of the debate about
racial post-modernism or racial post
structuralism in the mapping the margins
article print shaw identifies or
describes the debate in terms of the
debate between intersectionality on one
hand and anti essentialism on the other
and the big problem here has to do with
the utility of the social
constructionist thesis about what race
is the claim was at the time that race
is a social construction that race has
no biological reference and that when we
talk about race we're talking about
something which relies for its force on
a set of imaginings on a field of
imagining
not on something that we can actually a
tribute to or identify in the bodies of
actually existing human beings now
Prince Shaw said even if that's true
what follows from that ought we to build
the politics on the claim that race is a
social construction right what would
that politics have done for example if
we look at some of the canonical cases
in constitutional anti-discrimination
law such as Plessy versus Ferguson in
Plessy versus Ferguson challenge was
made to Louisiana law which mandated
racial segregation on public railways in
the state of Louisiana Homer Plessy
challenged that law and he did so by
making two different arguments that were
combined in the case the first argument
was that the very idea of race that
underwrote the Louisiana law was
incoherent plus he himself under the
system of racial classification than
enforce was one eighth black he was in
other words an octoroon in the province
of the time but he looked he looked
white and you know i'm about to think
here um i have blood sugar problems and
i cannot really breathe unless you open
either window or a door or something
yeah can I have that glass of water
thanks
so Prince House argument is she asked
the question what as a matter of
practical anti-racist politics in 1896
the year the Plessy was decided should
Plessy and his lawyers have argued
should they in attacking the statute
have argued that the category of race
was incoherent or should they instead
have argued whatever the coherence or in
coherence of race that the meanings
attached to race were being deployed in
the service of maintaining a regime of
racial subordination that violated the
Equal Protection Clause of the
Fourteenth Amendment crenshaw's own
preferences for the latter right because
no anti-racist politics can get
attraction of the kind necessary to
organize people of color at that time
are with with a a free and unmoored I
think that's the word I want to use with
an unborn a conception of race such as
the conception the the ante essentialist
conception of race that informs a social
constructionist theories similarly in
Brown versus the Board of Education
decided some 50 years later on the
parties could have argued that the
system the understanding of race that
assigned young Linda Brown to a school
for colored children instead of to her
local neighborhood school which was
predominantly white that the the
understanding of race by which Brown was
assigned to her public school was
incoherent or the argument could have
been made and this is the argument that
was made and won the case ah that it was
the meaning attached to the category of
race whatever its coherence or lack
thereof and the use of that meaning as a
justification for the subordination of
african-americans that
to be attacked right so the position
that intersectionality advances as a
matter of practical politics might
fairly be described as a kind of racial
pragmatism and this pragmatism positions
itself against a racial post modernism
which takes the social constructionist
theory all the way down and which views
the claim that race is a social
construction right for that race is an
idea a word a concept that is used to
construct social reality is not
disempowering but liberating in ways
that the theory of intersectionality it
seems to me overlooks and so in my
remaining five minutes I have a terrible
sense of time in my remaining five
minutes I think I just want to offer
some examples of what it might mean to
take the idea of race as a coalition
which is a concept with which crenshaw
ends the mapping the margins article
what it might mean to take that idea
seriously and whether in fact a
coalition of politics of the kind Prince
Shaw describes and mapping the margins
is a politics that in fact might have to
move beyond the understanding of
identity that informs intersectionality
and indeed perhaps beyond
intersectionality as such I want to
offer a few examples that seem to me to
complicate in ways that forces us to
that force us to reckon with this
question the
limits of intersectional politics very
briefly I really only have five minutes
I have one minute well I can't i right I
wanted to talk about Condoleezza Rice
but I wanted to talk about Condoleezza
Rice in the context of a contemporary
anti-racist politics and what it seems
to me are the uses and limits of an
intersectional understanding of the
figure of a Condoleezza Rice and and
here if I had the time I would rely on
the work of Jacqueline Rose most
especially on an article that she
published in her book of essays why war
called Ruth Ellis and Margaret Thatcher
Ruth Ellis was one of the last people
and certainly the last woman who was
executed in England under that states
regime of capital punishment and you all
know even the youngest among you I hope
who Margaret Thatcher was Margaret
Thatcher presided over what amounted to
radical transformation of English
society and politics and its concerted
move to the right and one of the things
that Margaret Thatcher was most proud of
during her term as Prime Minister was
her conduct two things one her conduct
of the falklands war and to the
introduction of the proposal that
capital punishment be reintroduced in
the UK so here we have an example of a
woman in Margaret Thatcher who was not
the victim of violence right in a sort
of stereotypical association that we
often have on the question of what the
relationship of women to violence is but
was the agent of violence similarly when
we look at Condoleezza Rice here we have
a black woman who
bodies in some very meaningful sense the
idea of the post racial state right and
who deploys her identity as a black
woman in the service of a political
project which inflicted untold suffering
on people of color around the globe
right men and women so what do we do and
asking the question about the utility
the contemporary of utility of
intersectionality with someone like the
figure of Condoleezza Rice arm
Condoleezza Rice we learned after she
had left the White House was the first
person in the bush administration to
give approval to the policy of torture
that we call waterboarding she was an
agent of violence she was uh in fact um
a woman who stood at the summit of the
phallic power of the state now it's not
clear to me that the terms of the
analysis of intersectionality which
position at its center someone like
Anita Hill right this woman caught
between two narrative tropes the Rope of
the trope of Ray on one hand the trouble
of lynching between feminist discourses
and anti-racist discourses it's not
clear to me that the figure of Anita
Hill represents what black womanhood or
is in the age if you will of a
Condoleezza Rice now obviously I don't
mean to suggest that all black women or
even maturity attract women occupy the
position of power and privilege of a
Condoleezza Rice what I am suggesting
however is that a figure such as
Condoleezza Rice forces us to think in a
way perhaps that the theory of
intersectionality does not provide the
to do about the ways in which are within
a dynamic understanding of race not just
at the end of gender not just his
identity but as identification we cannot
assume that gender is the name we give
or indeed that race is a name that we
give to a certain powerlessness before
the state in the figure of Rights we
recognize the ways in which both race
and gender can become terms and
operational tools for the elaboration of
and the consolidation of the racial
state as a post-racial state and of the
patriarchal state as a state which is
managed by or can be managed by women so
at the contemporary at this particular
moment I think some of the work that
intersection lists might want to think
about doing is how we can generate
categories for understanding this new
conjuncture where women are are not seen
as only or perhaps even primarily as the
objects or the targets of power but
themselves represent embody activate and
deploy a state power in the service of
projects which hurt other women as well
as men I have gone over my time there
are few other examples that we may be
able to bring out in the discussion
happening you want to study one switch
right um that window doesn't open
right i aint funny now oh I'm sorry oh
my goodness
okay I feel like the third wheel on a
bicycle because I am neither I not do
not work in the law i am not a legal
scholar and i'm not really going to be
talking about some of the legal
ramifications of concept of
intersectionality I thought maybe I was
just projecting that my role here was to
think about the way in which
intersectionality not as it is
specifically defined within critical
race theory or legal theory about the
way it has traveled beyond that as an
analytical rubric in other fields and my
training is a literature comparative
literature but it's broadly you know
cultural studies and all those soft
humanities so the language will be a
little bit different listen to me I also
wanted to say that but I think also my
role was to bring in the post-colonial
perspective because the Center for
critical analysis social difference is
trying to think about these keywords in
a global way so I feel that my role is a
is is to think about what happens to
analytical rubrics once we start to
globalize or once we chart start to
think about them in terms of global
perspectives and particularly to think
about post-colonial perspectives that
said I think it's important to note that
in the US the intersectionality is a
naming of women of color politics that
can really be removed from the political
struggles of women of color in a
particular space and time having having
been located in California for for many
many years I find that women of color
politics to be very important to
thinking about concepts in terms of
concepts in struggle and so this is not
just a theoretical not a you know
free-floating unmoored theoretical
concept but really connected to a
particular
social movements and their intervention
particularly in a moment of feminists
enfranchisement I think but it's long
operative in social struggles against
the endemic injuries of domination and
subordination alright so that's it
internet intersectionality we've already
heard as emerging out of the critique of
anti-discrimination law it is to a
certain extent could be thought of an
extension or expansion of an
anti-discrimination law and so from the
side from the outside at this points to
its predicate predication on what I
would call the grid of intelligibility
of the liberal state meaning to say you
know a grid of intelligibility that
makes sense of abstract citizens who
then become socially differentiated in
mark so what what this suggests is that
there is a hegemony of us race relations
that can be operative once this analytic
you know gets on word from its
particular social and political context
particularly the hegemony of a notion of
a juridical notion of subjectivity which
reinforces a conception of racism sexism
as identity-based forms of oppression
where identity is conceptualized as
positionality within a specialized field
of representation that's this is all
abbreviated for those of you who are not
who are not in that law but what what it
neglects is a conception for example of
subjectivity as time in post-colonial
theory the conception of subjectivity
subjectivity as times been very
important people like a shield in Bombay
or as constituted by heterogenous
temporalities of formation of personhood
and experience that are not encapsulated
by the notion of social identities or
identity subjects on this dura t'kul
model if you recall your photo the
fabrication of the individual within
disciplinary societies or within liberal
government allottees is also
commensurate with
fabric with the production of the
liberal state and they go hand in hand
and so I'm trying to say that this is
the context in which social identities
becomes a grid of intelligibility for
thinking about racism sexism homophobia
another another limit I think when you
globalize is to think about how now once
you get out of the contemporary
situation or even the 20th century how
an attention to individuals as these
rights varying subjects which
philosophically is conceived out of
historical related burrell secular
nationalism how this can restrict our
understanding of gender race and
sexuality to a specific cultural logic
of operation and it tends to reify these
categories and this is what I mean when
I'm not really talking about the
formulation of intersectionality and the
law but I'm talking about the mantra of
race gender sexuality seeing us you know
as axes but that's really the discourse
that i'm talking about unit of a
familiar notion of race gender sexuality
as axes of social identity but it tends
to reify them as empirical forms of
identity and difference on what i would
call the level of exchange social
exchange in a liberal state so what is
delighted by this conception one I think
is the processes of constitutions of
persons person hoods or lived experience
that exceed or fall short of this
subject ification process to the
processes of constitution of the
categories themselves as effects of
other processes for example let's say
economic processes in my own work for
example when I look at domestic workers
in households the Philippine domestic
workers who are who are imported into
households in either industrialized
countries or in other Asian countries
that racial difference
not so much that the forms of violence
that they face is not so much racially
based but that in fact the violence is
the technology for the production of
racial difference among women who may be
conceived as in terms of gendered
sameness because of the position that
they that they occupy within the
household that you take the place of the
mother you become kind of a replicant
mother or a replicant use the word
replicant or a replicant caregiver or so
forth so that the the woman who you know
from the outside is not racially
distinguishable from you know that the
domestic worker that violence becomes
the way of in scribing racial difference
or in the or the way that Hortense
pillars as a way of undoing gendered
sameness in those situations um so just
the thinking about you know identity
producing forms of differentiation and
that this inscription of difference
between let's say the employer and the
domestic worker has a very specific
economic function which is of course to
do value persons in order to extract the
difference between persons economically
the difference between how much I get in
terms of a wage and how much the
employer gets for their income ok so the
third thing that I see that that kind of
the Cobra calling intersectionality
anyway might elide is processes of life
production practices of living beyond
this grid of intelligibility of social
identities and given social identities
for example forms of making of sociality
that can't be folded into a multiplied
or intersectional race and gender and
class making again this is when I think
about my own work when I think about the
making of domestic labor within the
Philippines in the context of the
transition of the Philippine economy
that there are forms of life production
forms of engagement
social movements that is part of the
making of this class and gender or
however you might put it that don't
necessarily issue from the same kinds of
ideas of racism and sexism that you have
in the United States so different logics
basically um later when poets and
activists take up domestic labor they
also reframe the experiences of this
this overseas community of overseas
labor and then they expand it I
particularly write about a poet who
expands the experiences of domestic
labor to think about it in relationship
to other forms of colonial labor so that
the the framing of that experience
changes the lived experience of this
gender class sociality in other words
political reframing zuv experience also
have effects on experience and so it's
not the logic not just the logics of
domination that create the experiences
but also the political framings um so
this is just to reinforce the point that
the notion of social identity as the
analytical starting point you know as
the basis of discriminatory practice in
some of the in some of the ways that
this concept has traveled or the race
gender sexuality mantra reifies the
processes that produce social identity
as a social fact and reifies the
processes that produce it as a grid of
intelligibility and those processes
including and implicate the law itself
being to say that the law itself helps
to create and reinforce the social
identities and that we have to factor in
the those processes in understanding and
understanding racism and sexism so one
of the things that I've seen in
colonial work and then it's developing
now is the need for other genealogies of
racism and sexism and homophobia not
just as identity based but identity
producing socially socially
differentiating practices of not to
suppression largest discrimination but
dispossession exploitation life
production by political management death
exception sovereignty rule in wars and
over a whole host of other processes
that go beyond the US national history
mm but in fact that we need these
genealogies that recognize the role of
socially differentiating practices
within the very institutions of justice
and reparation and you know many have
made this point before our racism of
your slavery that's embedded in the
penitentiary system sexuality within
Slave Law colonial racism that's
embedded in the norms of human right the
notion of the human that operates there
so we have to look at those institutions
as well not just from the perspective
the institutions but the role of those
institutions in creating and furthering
this grid of intelligibility and that's
where I would say that intersectionality
in its legal framework continues to be
useful because of the globalization of
the rule of law through the
globalization of liberal democracy in
the democratizing projects of the US
State so on the one hand i'm arguing on
a practical level it's actually quite
important because of all the human
rights claims that are no now going on
globally on the other hand i'm saying
that we're also a facing or perhaps
alighting in maybe in the in the terms
that Kendall said in in favor of this
pragmatism of attending to the forms of
violation to these other grids of its
social intelligibility um I have very
little time left so I will just give you
a little one more example of how we can
expand beyond US national history
there's a lot of work now on Empire that
when it's my point is not just that we
have to think about things beyond the US
National History but we also have to
think about the way the very
institutions within the US have been
framed have been created in the context
of Imperial relations a long history of
us imperial relations so just as an
example the surveillance state there's
been work on the way in which the US
colonization of the Philippines for
example since this is where my work is
um helped to create the perfect and to
refine the US state as a surveillance
state how many of the covert enter
operations counterintelligence and so
forth were where were initiated in the
colonial laboratory I mean you're must
be familiar with some of these arguments
about the colonial laboratory has to be
figure has to be part of that US
national history of its installment
institutions of races not just racism
but its own Institute its own legal
institutions and then not just legal
another example is the way in which the
colony served as a laboratory for the
creation of new practices of what they
call the new American Public Health the
new American public health system and
how practices of social differentiation
or racialized intelligence also happens
through institutions of public health
the census its relationship to colonial
surveillance that's another example in
which the colonies figure into the kind
of bio political management in the the
United States so my point here in
thinking about you know the colonial
periphery in understanding
intersectional forms of racism in the
United States or understanding it
providing a different genealogy is that
if we are only thinking of
intersectionality as a concept for
tracking logics of domination
that operate in this in the context of
liberal democratic political
representation I think that we we miss a
lot and when the intersectionality is
made into an explanatory rubric meaning
to say that's the thing that you're
looking for an object of analysis that
obscures and deflects attention from not
only social processes outside of or
beyond the juridical framework of us
civil society but also alternative
genealogies of these social
differentiating I keep saying social
difference because of the of the center
you know the way that we are produces
individuals that there are other
genealogies I think that people are
working on and the forms and practices
of personhood sociality and subjectivity
in short other forms of life that are
operative in people's struggle to
survive to renew and change their viable
and individual and collective existence
and it is those other practices that at
least in the case of post-colonial
frameworks ties it back to women of
color struggles because it is thinking
about the way populations that are are
deemed disposable also remake themselves
and try and in doing so that they both
invent and rely on other forms of social
intelligence and social and other forms
of intelligibility and that I think
politically that's a very important
thing to pay attention to
you